so yeah welcome to session 20 of atcs so
this is the second quantum session
and we have uh some talks on quantum
complexity theory uh and the first
speaker is abhinav deshpande who talks
about uh who talked to us about the
importance of the spectral gap in
estimating ground state energies
so yeah abhinav you have you can share
your slides and
can you see this
no
um
[Music]
okay yeah
yeah hi everyone thanks for coming um so
today i'll be speaking about
uh this work the importance of the
spectral gap in estimating ground state
energies this is joint work with alexey
gauschko and bill pefferman uh alex is
at the university of maryland and bill
is at the university of chicago
he has the archive reference
um so let me start with the motivation
and first by defining what i mean
um
so studying ground states is an
important
field in
physics and maybe more generally across
all of the sciences
um
so in this we are interested in finding
the ground state of an object called the
hamiltonian which
is simply you can think of it as a
function that maps a given
state or configuration of a system to
some cost function or an energy
and we want to minimize this cost
function
and the ground state is simply the
minimum energy configuration of some
system
uh so no wonder it's useful in a lot of
places like transmitter quantum
chemistry and optimization
so
one question we can ask is how feasible
is um
studying ground states of general
hamiltonians
uh and
in the quantum setting
uh hamiltonians are simply
exponentially large emission matrices
and the ground state is now just the
minimum eigen value eigen state
uh so in this in the quantum setting
there's this famous local hamiltonian
problem
uh where
let's say we are given as input a
description of some n-cubit hamiltonian
h which is the sum of uh terms h i
and
this hamiltonian is local meaning that
each term h i acts on most say k cube
it's non-trivial
and as output we want to estimate the
minimum eigenvalue of h
um so i have showed um way back in 2001
2002
that it's qma hard to
solve this problem
uh if you care about inverse polynomial
additive error
um and qma is
a quantum generalization of this class
np so it's unlikely that quantum
computers can solve this problem in
general
uh more recently uh this problem has
been uh studied for inverse exponential
additive error
and it was uh shown to be p space hard
yours actually shouldn't be p space
complete
and this is what we call uh the precise
regime because we are interested in
really precise
uh estimates of the ground state energy
um so in this work we'll look at two
ways of adding structure to the problem
um so the first structural property
we'll study
is the spectral gap
um the spectral gap is simply the
difference between the
two smallest eigen values of the
hamiltonian
and
we want to study a variant of the
problem where we are promised to have
some spectral gap
okay so
we want to decide between these two
cases
in the s case the ground state energy is
smaller than some threshold a
and in the no case it's larger than some
threshold b
and
b and a are separated by some value
delta little delta which is the promise
gap
so the spectral gap is this difference
between the
smallest two eigenvalues and in both the
yes and the no case we are assured that
it's at least a large delta
so these two are the important
parameters in the problem
uh so again little delta is the promised
gap and capital delta is the spectrum
um the second structural property will
be concerned with is
whether you can have um
small circuit complexity of the ground
state
so
in this variant of the problem we have
the same parameters as before
plus we have the extra promise that
there is some polynomial size circuit to
prepare a low energy state
and in this promise we don't really care
about whether
finding such polynomials as circuits is
easy or not
ah again so okay we have the same
parameters
and
one interesting thing about this problem
is that if you have uh such a polynomial
size description of a circuit to prepare
a low energy state
then the quantum
then that can be
uh sent as a classical witness to the
quantum verifier
so for the experts this is the analogous
the analog of qma where
the witness is classical so that's qcma
and in this work we'll be concerned with
this precise setting
where the promise gaps are all
exponentially small
and
so when you don't have a spectral gap
meaning that you just have a vacuous
promise that the spectral gap is at
least zero
um
then these uh problems that i just
mentioned about the local hamiltonian
are complete for these classes precise
qma and precise qcma
which is just the analogues of qma and
qcma
with exponentially small difference
between the completeness and some of
these parameters
and it turns out that uh yeah these
classes are
quite powerful precise qma equals p
space and precise qcma is actually np to
the pp
okay so um
prior to this work yeah we so this is
what we knew so far uh
in the vacuous promise case
um it's p space complete with a quantum
witness and np to the pp complete with
the classical weakness
so our first result is that uh when you
add a spectral gap of at least inverse
polynomial
um the complexity goes from p space to
pp so
this extra promise sort of reduces the
complexity
and now uh let's see what happens when
we add this
promise again of
the being an a classical witness
in that case actually the two classes
coincide um so it's pp complete again in
this case
uh so this means there's an equivalence
between
some variant of qma and the same variant
of gcma
um
so that's it
so we've seen that the spectral gap can
make the problem easier
and the fact that these two classes are
the same
might raise the question of whether the
spectral gap promise is stronger than
the low circuit complexity promise
so maybe if the spectral gap promise
implies this other promise
um then that would explain um why these
two classes coincide
and this interest this is an interesting
conjecture because
if it's true it would explain why say
heuristic algorithms to find ground
states uh seem to work well in practice
today
uh yeah and there are open questions
about uh what the case is what the
constant spectral gap case looks like
and how this would look like in the
non-precise regime where
the promised gap is polynomially small
and so on
and i end with the limit
could i compute a ground state energy
depends how precise you want me to be it
also depends on the gap so here we give
you a map of where it's p space and
where pp
okay with that i thank you
thank you now yeah so yeah i asked all
the authors to write a numeric for it i
i was prepared for the discussion but
thanks i mean i've already for for
okay saying it already
yeah and uh yeah and the idea is that
each one of these speakers will give
their talk and then we have all the
questions at the end in a discussion
phase sure sure yeah okay
yeah
uh
so now we move to the second talk
and we have shining shoe would tell us
about the quantum
meets the minimum circuit size problem
i uh
oh yes i can share screen now
okay
hi everyone can can you hear me clearly
yeah i think it's pretty good yeah
right and uh yeah hello everyone i'm
tuning from harvard
and today i'm going to talk about this
joint work with nikoi jiaoyu and razer
um quantum meets the minimum circuit
size problem
yeah and also i cannot keep track of
time so let me know like if i only have
one minute left
yes
okay so maybe let me start with uh like
define defining quarter minimum circuit
size problem in the original classical
setting to everyone
so in this computational problem the
input is the truth table of unbids a
boolean function and the size parameter
s yeah so this is like the truth table f
and the output is yes if there is six
circuits that compute this uh boolean
function of size and voltage s and
otherwise well
no
so notice that this computational
problem is slightly different in the
sense that the input length is 2 to the
n so when we say polynomial time it is
actually like a probably 2 to the n so
it's like 2 to the 1.
and also a quick observation is that
this mcsp problem actually is in mp
because there is a very simple weakness
you can have it's just a circuit of size
s and we know that s will be at most 2
to the n
and the verification can just process
can just like evaluate all the
input and check whether it match
the uh truth table
yeah so this is definitely an mp
algorithm
yeah but it turns out that this is
basically the best we know about the
basic uh complexity result of this mcsp
problem
and furthermore like whether mcsp in p
or mcsp being np-hard is a long-standing
very difficult problem and there are
actually also lots of barrier results
showing that proving either
requires some
new techniques that's beyond the current
complexity series
results
and furthermore actually the best
algorithmic results we know for solving
mcsp actually is still brute force and
search and some people even conjecture
this is the case
okay so why mcsp like it seems that we
although it's natural problem and it
seems that we we still don't know it
really well but it turns out that in a
setting of classical uh like a
complexity theory mcsb connects to lots
of different sub areas in tcs including
circuit complexity learning theory every
case complexity and cryptography
so this is like um i mean the original
motivation for us like oh what if we now
study the mcsp problem in a quantum
setting maybe it also has lots of
connections to different subfields in
like a tcs of quantum complexity
and perhaps like through the lens of
ncsp in a content setting this can give
us some new insights
yeah so as a starter to
like investigate the mcsp problem in the
content setting yeah we now need to like
transfer from like boolean circuits to a
content circuits
but immediately quantum circuits are
different from like boolean circuits
because now a common circuit
corresponding to a unitary
transformation like this in general we
have like lots of input input qubits and
some ncr qubits and the content circuits
is like intrinsically compute some
unitary transformation so there are
actually three natural types of
computation you can think of
the common cell you can implement
first you can still implement a boolean
function in a sense that you you look at
the marginal probability of the sailor
first output qb with a lot of generality
and use it to determine whether the
output is 0 1
and in the meantime you can also look at
the content state this is related to the
previous talk where now maybe you fix
the input qubit to some like all zero
state with a lot of generality and look
at the output state as your output
and also you can think of oh the whole
unitary transformation is the function
you want to compute so this is already
suggesting that if we want to study mcsp
in a content setting there are three
natural uh like setting we can consider
and we actually consider all of them but
in order to properly define actually it
requires some extra efforts but i won't
describe here but you're welcome to look
at our paper
so this is a birth eye view of the
result we proved so we we have lots of
results but basically they can
categorize into three categories
and the first one is a marked blue
in blue it is like some results that's
already appear in classical mcsp study
and basically by some
direct
like techniques we can prove it
and there's also some yellow results
actually requires some extra techniques
yeah so that we can also prove it in the
chromosome setting
but the more interesting result probably
is the red results where we prove some
content unique results for example we
actually can show that for certain type
of uh
content and csp like for the state
version and the unitary version we
actually can have some cool reductions
that is not known in the technical
settings for example some self-reduction
or search to decision reduction etc
and for the search uh
sorry the state version of the mcsp we
also connected it to something like a
pseudorandom state etc
so it also suggests that yeah by as an
initial study of mcs being a content
setting your your own is connecting to
lots of different areas and also
something that's only unique in the
content settings
yeah and also like the study of
mcsp in content setting actually is not
immediate and trivial it's still lots of
barrier we need to concur and here i
just listed three big categories so it's
like the common computation in general
is erroneous and random rather i mean as
compo as opposed to the classical
boolean circuits
and also the introduction of the
ancillary qubits turns out to be a
little bit subtle
and also it turns out a lot of our
result actually specials to the gate set
choice of the content circuits and this
is also something
quite weird
and so just want to give people feeling
feeling like actually it's not an
immediate uh like uh extension from the
classical setting there's still some
technical challenges
okay so in the rest of my talk yeah i
hope i can use one to two minutes to
convince you there are some interesting
things in the content study of mcsp
especially on talk about this example of
content unique reduction but there are
more and you are welcome to look at the
wrong talk or the
paper
so let's let me use the state version of
lens csp to explain this corner unique
reduction
so in a state version the input now
becomes uh becomes a content state and
maybe we have lots of copies and a size
parameter s and the goal is exactly
asking you whether there's a circuit of
size s that prepare this state
and now i'm going to show so this is a
decision problem and the search problem
is to find the circuits for me
and now i'm going to show you that to
convince you that actually there's a
search to decision reduction
and in particular
okay we also actually also have
self-reduction and other
gap version reduction yeah
and the key ideas are following we can
leveraging the uh
the reversibility of the content
circuits to construct to find us to
search like to find the circuits using
just the decision
so now with the input is a content state
and we have a decision oracle we can
guess across the uh the last gate one by
one and query this decision oracle and
if it output node can try the other one
and yes and then we guess the other one
so we can keep redo doing this and it is
because the reversibility property of
the uh content circuit so that we can
keep a query in this decision oracle
and of course this is actually not
exactly true to make it work actually
require some techniques but the
interesting open problem is then oh is
there any application of this kind of
content unix reductions
okay so as a quick summary yeah we study
like uh the mcsc problem in the content
setting in particular our result
basically can categorize into three uh
states steps the first steps we study
the boolean
version and then we also in the second
step consider some content objects and
finally we started some content unique
phenomenon in the mcsp three lengths of
ncsp
so let me conclude with some future
direction i'm not sure how much time i
have left but uh i just maybe stopped
here and uh thanks for your attention
and you're welcome to ask me questions
in the panel discussion or read our
paper
thanks everyone
thanks a lot jimmy so just to remind
everyone so yeah we'll leave all the
questions to the end for our panel
discussion
so now we will move to the next talk
where gregory rothenthal
will
tell us about interactive proofs for
synthesizing quantum states and
unitaries
thanks uh hi i'm greg rosenthal and yeah
this is joint work with henry ewan on
interactive proofs for synthesizing
quantum states and unitaries
so first let me talk about state and
unitary synthesis more generally and
then explain what i mean by the
interactive part uh with state synthesis
uh the globalistic instructor quantum
state uh say given
an encoding of that state in some
succinct reasonable way and there are
many examples of this in practice that
one might care about and uh similarly
with unitary synthesis that means the
goal is to apply some given unitary
transformation to a given input register
and again there are many examples of
this in practice
and relatively little is known about the
quantum complexity of constructing
states and implementing unitaries
compared to what is known about the
quantum complexity of decision problems
so why are these sort of problems
difficult
well they can be seen as quantum analogs
of function problems where in a function
problem the goal is to map an input
string to an output string but there are
at least three differences uh one is
that uh these uh quantum problems don't
have any clear reductions to decision
problems uh whereas with a function
problem uh computing each bit of the
output string it's uh
reduces is just a decision problem if
you compute each bit one by one but that
doesn't work here
uh second on n cubit state
has two to the n amplitudes which in
some sense makes it an exponentially
more complex object than a string
and finally in the case of the unitary
synthesis
because
like you know
like we don't know what was in the input
register it's impossible to even give a
classical description of the output
register regardless of any complexity
constraints
so in this paper we make progress toward
what can be seen as an analog for
quantum states and unitaries of the ip
equals p space theorem
so what do i mean by this we define
quantum state analogs of a bunch of
well-known
complexity classes such as p space and
qip
we proved that state p space is
contained in state qip and as a partial
converse we prove that state qip is
contained in state x
in the case of unitaries we don't get as
strong results we only prove that a
certain subclass of unitary p space is
contained in unitary qip
and also we get similar results using
without multiple entangled provers
rather than just a single prover
and uh
these proofs reduced to qip equals p
space and mip star equals re but these
reductions are non-trivial
so uh first let me uh describe the model
of computation um without state p like
qip and state p space for example
so the model is that uh there's a bqp
verifier that will exchange messages
with an untrusted quantum prover and the
prover cannot solve you know
as unbounded complexity
and these are quantum messages over
polynomially many rounds then the
verifier will accept or reject which so
far is exactly like the model of
computation in the complexity class qip
and now what's different is that uh when
the verifier accepts it also outputs a
quantum state
and these are the completeness and
soundness conditions that we would like
to hold for completeness there should
exist an honest prover strategy such
that with probability
one the verifier will accept and output
approximately the state that it's
supposed to output
and for soundness uh for all prover
strategies such that the verifier
accepts with non-negligible probability
the verifier's output state with this
prover strategy condition on accepting
should be approximately what it is
supposed to be
now
we defined state qip as the class of
state sequences with one state on each
number of qubits that can be synthesized
as above
uh more generally you could consider
states indexed by binary strings it
doesn't really matter we just need to
consider some infinite state family so
we can use asymptotic notation
uh unitary qip defined similarly
state p space uh
and it's defined more precisely in the
full version of the talk as our what i
mean by approximately here like this how
small error we can tolerate
so now in the next couple slides i'm
going to talk a bit about the proof of
state p space and say qip and
because of time i'm going to rush
through it but in the full version of
the talk i explained it more precisely
so uh first uh the starting point is a
protocol due to aronson with a trusted
prover uh for constructing a state but
where the approver is only allowed to
send classical messages
so the solution is uh write the target
state psi as
uh decompose it in this way uh first on
the verifier we'll query the values of
beta0 and beta1 to polynomial leave any
bits of precision construct this state
beta0 plus beta 1 1
uh then it uncomputes the query and then
uh controlled on the bit i in this one
qubit state that it constructed
recursively construct theta i
and it's important to uncompute garbage
because
we don't want garbage to be entangled
with the final state
so uh with an untrusted prover we can do
something similar because uh it turns
out for states and state p space these
queries can be computed in p space so uh
the verifier can run i p equals p space
and superposition and this will defend
against certain types of attacks uh like
cheating in the ip equals p space part
of the protocol but it won't defend
against quantum attacks and uh so in
this uh sub this uh thing here i give an
example say uh the approver just a
dishonest mover will uh in private like
construct uh some state fee sub x
controlled on query string x and you can
see how this fails down here so we're
actually pro actual protocol it's uh
like the one on this slide but it's a
variant of it that defends against these
sort of quantum attacks
okay and now let's talk about this
special case of unitary p space and
unitary qip
we say that a unitary has on acting on n
qubits as polynomial action if the
subspace that it acts non-trivial on has
dimension at most poly n
and this is done by a hamiltonian
simulation algorithm we showed that uh
if we write u equals e to the i t rho
then a certain purification of rho is in
state p space and the evolution time t
is computable in p space so then uh
using state p space equals state q i p
the verifier can construct copies of row
and compute t and use this hamiltonian
simulation algorithm
now with multiple entangled provers and
we prove that state r equals state qmip
where state r is like the quantum state
analog of r and this is uh very similar
to the uh proof of state p space
included in uh state uh uh qip or sorry
the other yeah that's right uh and the
reason i'll just briefly highlight why
it's uh state r and not state re is i
here uh when we on the verifier brute
forces over all approvers to find the
honest prover uh this has it's
guaranteed to terminate because we
assume that an honest prover exists
and finally a bunch of open problems as
they keep oip and say p space can we
improve some of the approximation errors
in our
results can we reduce the number of
rounds we have a protocol with a
constantly many rounds that we
conjectured works but we haven't proved
it
uh is all of unitary p space and unitary
qip
uh as we suggested science polynomial
action units or ep space uh can the
protocol be generalized to mixed states
what if we required improvements to be
efficient what if the proofers are
unentangled interestingly on the proof
some of our proof steps break down if
the approvers are unentangled even
though it works if there are multiple
entangled provers or just a single
prover and finally is there an
interesting zero knowledge notion of
satan unitary synthesis or cryptography
applications
thank you
thank you gregory
uh
and now okay we move to the next talk
where darren rudolph will
deliver his talk on polynomially many
queries to np or qma oracles
yeah thank you um can you see my screen
and this is
okay
yeah so my talk is on polynomially many
queries to np or qma oracles which is
joint work with silver caribbean at
paderborn university
first i go over the motivation of this
research and prior work
one may ask the question what lies
beyond np
we have the polynomial hierarchy of
complexity classes p e p to the n p p to
the n p to the n p and so forth
on the second level of ph
there's delta to p or p to the np
generally we say p to the c for the
complexity class that can be solved um
yeah
generally we say p to the c
for the complexity class that can be
solved by a polynomial time turing
machine with access to an article for a
c complete problem
to gain intuition note that co-np is
contained in p to the np
by restricting the queries the turing
machine is allowed to perform one can
define weaker complexity classes
in p to the np-log the turing machine
may ask at most algorithmic number of
oracle queries
in p to the parallel np it must ask all
its queries at the same time so the
queries cannot logically depend on each
other
generally in p to the np the ith query
depends on the answers to all previous
queries
we can model these dependencies as a dag
as shown on the right here
we interpret this graph as a circuit in
which each node performs a single query
with some preprocessing and then sends
the curry answer along the outgoing
edges
by restricting the structure of the
query graph one can define complexity
classes that lie between p to the
parallel and p which has been shown to
be equal to p to the np log and p to the
np
recall that p to the parallel np has
non-adaptive queries so they are not
connected in the graph
therefore we add an output node
representing the turing machine
computing the final output from the
carry answers
god loop considers the restriction of
chary graphs to trees and shows that the
resulting class
called trees of np is equal to p to the
np-log and our work is largely based
upon this result
and yeah we have the quantum analog of
np called qma quantum merlin arthur
and a p to the q a log has the
physically well motivated complete
problem apx sim or approximate
simulation of simulating measurements on
the ground state of a hamiltonian
this raises the question whether the
results for p to the np log also
translate over to the quantum setting
here p to the parent qma equals p to the
qma log has recently been shown
but it was not known until this work
whether the result for query trees also
holds
next i present the main results of our
work
we consider a complexity class c of the
given set you can assume qma or ma if
you prefer for this talk
and we define the class c deck s
of characters with a bounded separator
number s here the separator number s of
g is defined as the minimum s such that
every subgraph of g has a balanced
separator of size at most s
note that the separator number is
bounded by tree
width similarly defined cd as the class
of cherry graphs of bounded depth d
and now the main theorem is that a query
graph of separator number s can be
solved by turing machine and time due to
the s log log n
using s log and c queries
so for a constant separator number we
obtain that c dash s is equal to p to
the c log for a constant s
this improves the previous classical as
well as quantum results
for a polylogarithmic separator number
we get a quasi-polynomial time base with
a poly logarithmic number of queries
analogous results hold for query graphs
of bounded depth
next we apply these results to ap exim
guitarev uses a circuit to hamiltonian
mapping in his quantum cook-levin
theorem to embed a quantum circuit
computation into a hamiltonian
the lifting glamour then embeds
non-adaptive qma queries into apx-sim
preserving certain geometric properties
of the underlying circuit to hamiltonian
mapping such as locality for example the
idea behind these geometric properties
is to make the hamiltonian more like a
physical system
we extend this result to a generalized
lifting lemma by providing a polynomial
time many redund
manual reduction directly from query
graphs
of bounded separator number or depth to
apix sim that again satisfies geometric
properties
now let's go over a few open problems so
we show that for poly logarithmic
separator number c deck s is contained
in qp with poly logarithmic c queries is
the quasi polynomial time base really
necessary here
can we extend our results to further
complexity classes such as qma1 with
perfect acceptance probability uqma with
a unique accepting proof a starcrastic
for which only some of our results hold
and what is the exact relationship
between the separator number and tree
with um
can tree will ever exceed separate a
number by more than a constant factor so
we know it must a logarithmic factor
and finally i'll sketch the proof of our
main result the containment of qmadec
of bonded separator number and p to the
qmail log
for that we need to evaluate a
choreograph of constant separator number
with a logarithmic number of qma queries
on the right side you can see an example
query graph each node contains a quantum
circuit that receives outputs from
incoming edges as well as a proof
the idea now is to define a total
solution weight function t on the string
of query answers x
and approves psi 1 to psi n the function
is gi and force a correct
proof and a query string equal bit x i
f of v i is a weighting function that
prioritizes correct answers to queries
with more dependents
for example q1 in this example has a
higher priority than q3
we say a weighting function is
admissible if f of v is at least 1 plus
c times the weight on all outgoing
neighbors for some constant c
if f is polynomially bounded we can
approximate the maximum value of t with
a logarithmic number of qma queries
however f can in general be exponential
for example for a line graph
therefore we need to transform the graph
this proof follows a similar structure
to god loops but is adapted to
probabilistic promise classes especially
promise parents pose quite a challenge
which i elaborate on in the full talk
before the graph transformation we split
the graph recursively using balanced
separators to build a separator tree in
which each node corresponds to a
separator in the sub graph by induced by
its descendants
to transform the graph we create copies
of every node conditioned on nodes above
and in the same separator
for example we want to decouple the
nodes v1 and v2 so these two nodes here
and now in the transformed graph v2
chooses a copy of x2 conditionally and
so there's no longer this dependence
here of v2 and v1
and hence
there are only edges to ancestors in the
separator tree
and each node has therefore o of s times
log n descendants which polynomially
bonds the weighting function
lastly here is the total solution weight
function in more detail
g of i is defined such that if x i is
equal to 1
then gi is the acceptance probability of
the circuit q i
if x is equal to 0 then gi is set to one
half
therefore gi penalizes an incorrect x i
in the yes case there is a proof that is
accepted with probability at least two
thirds so by
choosing xl correctly we can increase gi
by at least one over six
compared to the incorrect x i
one can show two important lemmas
firstly it is possible to approximate
the maximum t
um
with qma queries
secondly if t is close to the maximum
then x must be a coaching string
therefore we can determine the correct
output x n
using binary search
thank you for listening
thanks darren
and we're heading out to the last uh
talk in the session and uh cinema nirke
will tell us about uh civic lower bounds
for lower energy states of quantum
called hematology
as far as yours
all right everyone hear me
okay
um hello uh thank you um
for coming yeah i'm gonna talk about a
result of honorarches and mine on
circuit lower bounds for low energy
states code hamiltonians
um
to start off the right question to think
about is that ground states of local
hamiltonians you know as we know are
highly entangled non-classical objects
that happen to capture universal
computation quantum computation but at
the same time we don't really understand
anything past the ground state our
understanding of low energy states
states which violates some fraction of
the
hamiltonian terms or violate
fractionally each hamiltonian term we
are really kind of clueless as to the
complexity of these states so the goal
of this paper is to somehow rigorously
analyze and understand how entangled and
non-classical states of low energy could
be and we'll do that in a very precise
manner
so to to preface there was a conjecture
formulated by friedman and hastings in
2014 called the nlts conjecture the no
low energy trivial states conjecture
which posited that there were
hamiltonians so physical systems one
could write down on a piece of paper
local
physical systems for which every state
of low energy
is highly entangled and non-classical
and they even provided a very rigorous
definition of highly entangled and
non-classical
and so these states are very nice
because as we've kind of discussed
previously these local hamiltonians they
don't they shouldn't have any classical
approximation for the ground state they
have um they can't be verified and say
np or whatnot
um and and they sort of form this very
interesting separation that we always
are looking for between quantum and
classical
and you can sort of think of this as a
state that if units started as a ground
sin you
you know connected to a heat bath and
let it thermalize a bit then it would
still be highly entangled
and so the goal of this work is to
actually kind of work towards the nlts
conjecture and it's to prove a circuit
depth lower bound for every low energy
state of local hamiltonians and we're
not going to prove it for all local
hamiltonians that would be impossible
but we're going to prove it for a
specific family of local hamiltonians
and those being local hamiltonians
corresponding to error corrected codes
so in this result is less of a
construction and more of a necessary
theorem that
[Music]
proves properties of all
error correcting codes and how does this
relate to nlts well the notion of highly
entangled and non-classical that
friedman and hastings conjectured was a
notion of circuit depth lower bound so
they're trying to understand what is the
minimum circuit depth required to build
a state and this is just a circuit where
you just take you know any two local
unitaries and you stack them one along
another and we're just
concerned at the depth of the circuit we
previous talks in this session discussed
this a little bit
so formally what is our result our
result said if you have a generic
stabilizer error correcting code
uh an nkd code where n's physical qubits
k is logical and d is the erasure
distance as long as the code is in ldpc
so it's got constant locality in both
sides
if you write out the corresponding local
hamiltonian which is just very simple
you just take a hamiltonian term for
every
code check and you just this is a linear
transformation but you know
and you take any low energy state
whether that be a mixed state or a pure
state so any state rho whose energy is
less than some number epsilon
then we should be able to prove a
minimum circuit depth of generating rho
and what exactly do we prove we prove
the following result the minimum depth
is at least the min of log d and log of
something i'm just going to say in a
second divided by n
times a small factor of epsilon and
what's very interesting about our result
is one would assume
that the number that should go in this
blue spot here is d the distance of the
code right distance would probably
suggest what is
the um
sort of gives the complexity but what we
actually show is that you can prove it
with k so as long as you can prove a
circuit lower bound there's like minimum
of log d and log k over n so the
relative rate itself seems to have a
value in proving circuit lower bounds
and that's probably one of the more
interesting parts of the result and then
we also show that you can actually
strengthen this to make this log of k
plus d
i'm hiding some stuff in the big o
factor but so you can show that either
if a code is high rate or high distance
you can prove very non-trivial circuit
lower bounds as to the depth of any low
energy state
so example is that if you have a linear
rate code and even polynomial distance
then anything of energy less than 0.99 n
to the point 99 is log n depth which is
optimal of the constants right there
so maybe some example codes as to where
this takes effect one idea is the helix
zemor code which is um this hypergraph
product code which is a very simple
construction has been around for a long
time since 2009 where they quickly got a
linear rate but the distance was only
square root n but the lower boundary
proof is just the same thing i just said
said of n to the 0.99 has log n depth a
more interesting construction sort of
defies our intuition as to what contains
high complexity of entanglement and
circuit depth and maybe kind of provides
insight into how we should think about
this is maybe the puncture torque code
that's where you take a torah code and
you may start making these little holes
these green areas where you just remove
the terms
associated with them and as long as you
space these holes out by like n to the
delta ish
distance between them then you get a
very high rate code and a very um
polynomial distance and you just kind of
apply the theorem and presto you get the
result that's written right there
right and it would behoove me not to say
um something about the recent results in
quantum ldpc codes and those codes are
linear rate and linear distance codes
these are the ones by parent 11 college
hev
but interestingly up to constants our
result is unable to prove anything
better about them so a very nice open
question to consider is whether we can
do better
based on the construction there but that
i my suspicion is that that would
involve really opening up their
construction whereas the results that we
state in this paper are very generic and
are properties of all ldpc stabilizer
codes
so maybe lastly which is why i think
this result is surprising i won't say
anything about how the proof techniques
you can watch the full version if that's
interesting to you but the result i
think is surprising because quantum
error correcting codes were designed to
correct discrete errors defined by the
physical cubits right the notion of
erasure distance is on physical qubits
and in contrast we're showing the
interesting property that low energy
states where even the low energy could
be fractional violation you can
partially violate all the checks in some
manner
the error correcting code somehow still
is able to
preserve this notion of high
entanglement despite not being designed
for this it's sort of
that somehow correcting discrete errors
seems to have some
properties of correcting continuous
errors in some strange sense and i i i
don't really know how to say more than
that but it certainly i think is the
most fascinating um
intuition that one should take from this
lastly i if i have time alex i could
just say a little bit about the quantum
pcb conjecture but looking at who's in
the crowd i suspect that this is almost
unnecessary
um
right so the quantum pcb conjecture as
you might know is trying to understand
is it qma hard to estimate the energy of
a local hamiltonian to a constant factor
and we're still jury still out on this
and we don't we don't know if it's true
and the nlts conjecture the conjecture
that you know we
set forth trying to solve in this
research is a simplification which
issues the notion of computation
from the problem and just asks
is there a family of local hamiltonians
where the circuit complexity is large
it's sort of
you we're it separates the
complexity of quantum states from the
notion of computation that's but which
are both inherent in the quantum pcb
conjecture so so um and we don't know
how to solve even the simplified version
yet so our work we hope can be seen as
some progress towards it but i still
think there's a lot to do and i hope to
you know keep thinking about this
problem more
um
so yeah that's the end of my talk i
guess are we doing lumerix alex so yeah
thanks chinway and yeah so now after the
talks we'll have a panel discussion and
as i ask the authors i
like
they they have
written a limerick for their work so i
ask each one of them to read their
limericks and then we can start asking
questions so i think chinmayo can start
like you have it already so
um yeah so uh this is my numeric i wrote
yesterday so
for years our community paused in
perplexity not understanding how to
lower bound the complexity of any low
energy state until we considered the
rate of codes protecting in a quantum
capacity
so
very good thanks to that challenge of
writing the limerick it was fun
and i think i asked now i've been up to
read his limerick again sure yeah uh
yeah do you see this
you see it now yeah
right yeah could i compute a ground
state energy depends how precise you
want me to be
it also depends on the gap so here we
give you a map
of where it's p space and where people
thanks again every now uh
who can really ask and dorian can you do
it now can you read yours
hey okay
each note in a graph asks an oracle yet
we seek to query logarithmical
so the weights ought to be light the
graph to be made tight when its
structure is aboriginal
yeah sorry guys i actually didn't
prepare it no no no
an analog for quantum states
of qip equals p space and similarly for
unitaries acting on a smallish subspace
thanks gregory and thanks for everyone
for like uh
keeping up the challenge i think yeah
last last year like uh okay this idea is
inspired by javier rubinstein he he
he proposed something like this last
year and i found it fun so i tried to
to put a bit more structure and ask the
authors again and thanks a lot it was
great
yeah thank you i had fun
and now okay let's go after some art
let's go let's go back to science so let
me know yeah
do we have questions so i think sev had
a question so do you want to
to ask it out loud or should i do it
um yeah it's up to you guys
go go on go on okay so thanks to all the
speakers great talks
um so jeanine i just had a quick
question for you um so normally of
course in quantum complexity we tend to
think of inputs to problems as being
classical
and so um but it looks like at the
at the end of your talk um for those
for the one result you highlighted the
input was quantum is that correct
or how are you representing it if not
uh yes so actually uh you know you know
people actually can define like
several different variants yeah you can
think of the yeah of course the state
being content objects but you can also
have a classical description but that
description might be a big circuit
itself so the question will then be like
oh can you have a smaller circuit for
the state completed by this sentence yes
[Music]
so yeah i have a really good question so
use i think you you have an open problem
that trying to prove if either of these
problems is in np
but we have okay we have some qma
completeness of some problems that are
related for example i think um
proving if um a unitary is non-identity
or if a circuit is not identical or
something like that this is uh qma
complete
uh do you have a thought if somehow like
having putting this in npu will
contradict i don't know would imply in p
equals m a or something like that
uh
yes so actually yeah i mean we do have
some similar very results yeah like
showing like if you have official
algorithm then you have lots of uh yeah
undesirable consequences yeah yeah but
in the meantime we also don't know how
to show this like qmi heart or something
stupid yeah and in fact the boot beam
version will show that it is in qc
anymore
yes
so
yeah probably you probably also won't
hope expect it to be and make complete
okay i see
thanks
uh anurag you have a question
oh hey uh great talk everyone um so
question from abhinav uh for his talk um
so uh
in the proof of pcp theorem uh denver's
proof of specific theorem there are
these steps which amplify the gap of a
hamiltonian
yeah which is unknown entirely in the in
the quantum case uh i wonder if the
presence of a gap in the hamiltonian
could help
uh
prove such results because you know
classical hamiltonians inherently have a
spectral gap
so i don't know if that is a valid
question here
so i believe yeah like to some extent
there are results
which show that you
cannot hope to have such um
you know spectral gap amplification
procedures wait are you talking about
the spectral gap what the problem is we
changed it so so yeah uh promise gap
amplification for a spectrally gapped
hammock
okay
problem is gap amplification for a
spectral gap
yeah so then we
we have a separation right between
precise qma and
or sorry precise you know the gapped
version of um the local amateur neutron
which we prove is pp complete right
uh
so
so i guess if you believe qma is not
equal to pp then we don't have um such
procedure
but precise regime is probably something
where the promised gap is exponentially
small is that correct
oh you're talking okay okay so about the
non-precise regime
right right so it boils down to whether
there's
such a separation right
um
my intuition like so if you believe the
conjecture that i was making uh is
that the spectral gap would reduce the
complexity even in the non-precise
regime so which would bring it down to
qcma in fact uh because the conjecture
is like a
um
it's a stronger version of what we prove
in fact
um yeah so i guess it all depends on
your prior on whether qma and qcma
differ
okay thanks
but yeah um actually i had a question
for chinmay
so before your
results what were like the best known
ones on
what the lower bound is for the circuit
complexity
yeah that's a that's a great question um
for certain restricted classes of states
there were known results for
log and lower bounds so states which you
know violated
um
specific hamiltonians they were like
those states called low error states but
i think
as far as i know before a result there
wasn't a well-known lower bound for all
states um of low energy other than under
energy like
order
and
n to the negative uh two or something
so that you can kind of come from like
circuit to hamiltonian reductions so
proving lower rounds for all states is
the principal difficulty
uh i'll also have a question regarding
your paper uh so
i didn't quite understand what is
missing from your results
that is not proving the uh conjecture
ah
our result our circuit lower bound is a
small dependence on the epsilon factor
so as absolu so it's not proven for some
fixed constant epsilon
so if you fix the concept of epsilon you
only get um
a uh
yeah for iron for a fixed constant
epsilon you get a fixed constant lower
bound you don't get a super constant
lower bound if that makes sense
oh yeah okay thank you
questions
actually i have a uh okay go on
okay i have a question to abner so at
the end you said that somehow your
results explain why we can
we do have heuristics for these problems
but the end of the day like you prove pp
hardness right so yeah
can you comment on that yeah
sure yeah uh so i was talking about the
stronger version of the uh result that
we didn't prove did not prove so it
would be the conjecture that i was
making oh which is saying that
polynomial size circuits exist to
prepare low energy states and which is
like a minimum requirement for these
algorithms to work in the first place
okay and uh another question so uh
the spectral gap i imagine is only
important for perfect soundness right
for completeness you don't really care
about it
or am i wrong
uh can you repeat it's only important
for what for for proven soundness
somehow for the sound is part of the
proof and not for completeness or am i
wrong
uh
let's see
so if like when we want to show the
upper bound
um
of pp
we do need the spectral gap there okay
oh i see i see
because otherwise you can't do it
precisely um
yeah
oh i see so man okay and but then i
imagine that for completeness then do
you need so do you need spectral gap on
both sides for completing the soundness
on upper and upper like an upper bound
maybe just into one and lower bound just
in the other or you need both spectral
gaps on both sides
i see like in both the yes and the no
cases you mean yeah yeah
yeah so we
i think we can do away with the spectral
gap in the no case
um because yeah i think um yeah we use
one of sales results um
on how or was it anderson's results
where
you know if you have a spectral gap you
can in fact compute
spectral gaps in pp
um
so yeah like we sort of check for
spectral gaps and if it exists we just
apply our pp algorithm and if it doesn't
exist then yeah then we say no
okay thanks
so i think sev had a question
yeah let me just also quickly comment
that like intuitively i would expect
that the spectral gap should come in in
the upper bound right because usually
having a spectral gap helps with state
preparation like exactly these things
where you project onto the ground state
or things like this like so
that's the feeling i have
uh
sorry the question i had was going to be
for a chimney
so you mentioned these um
the recent coding breakthrough right
you're not able to uh hijack that
in your framework right um
so what what exactly do you have a sense
of what breaks down i'm just curious
like
oh no nothing
breaks down per se
okay yeah it's just that the
the
lower bounds we get are
depend on log d right like one
assumption you make is you sort of take
a correctable region so the best bound
you're going to get is log of the
distance so improving distance from root
n to n
doesn't really help with improving our
result in in that sense maybe
more specific about the way the
construction is built or it's like these
tessellation of these kind of squares
yeah that's right
something would have to be used there
to argue um
uh the bound we have some ideas i mean i
can discuss
in greater detail at other points um
there's sort of this
we have crude bounds as to how much like
this uh
errors propagate when you know
when you're a low energy state
um
and one hope is if that can that
an explicit construction can help us
sort of bound that better then you might
get it
[Music]
also i have another question for you
um is there some um
[Music]
wishful result which
you know if true and you plug in your
results would immediately yield um an
lts or um is there not such a thing
ah so there the wishful result is uh not
due to ourselves but there was a result
from 2015 by uh leor eldar and aaron
harrow which says that if you were able
to build a quantum locally testable code
so the you have to add the local
testability property
to
the
linear distance code
and in that one you didn't actually the
rate was independent
you were able to
kind of you were able to get the nlts
result and the intuition there is that
the local testability sort of lets you
switch from discrete errors to
continuous errors like it provides you
the tools to do that transformation the
surprising thing in our result is you
don't actually need it to do it but you
can't do it as nicely as you want
without it
so look yeah
okay yeah got it thanks
so yeah i have a question to gregory
so like yeah you showed that the
state r is equal to state key in my p
so why uh can i expect that you don't
need quantum communication or is it
somehow
intrinsic
like wait
why not state our equal state q online p
no
no yeah why it's not state mip star
oh oh sorry uh
oh yeah yeah statement star
yeah yeah that's what i meant
oh i see your question
i don't know henry's in the audience uh
yeah henry if you know how you can chime
in uh
yeah i think they should
it's not clear to me promote henry to
the panelists otherwise you can't talk
uh okay is sarah there he's an attendees
okay one second maybe i can do that
um i think they should be the same uh
now here we can talk if you want
hello can you hear me yeah yeah
oh yeah that's a great question so i
guess the
state mip star would be
a model where the verifiers quantum the
provers are quantum but the
communication is classical yeah yeah
um
that's a good question i don't know um
mike my hunch is henry you can't do
anything because at the end of the day
the blocks that the verifier has to
build with are like polynomial circuits
of clifford gates and t-gates right so
like the
he's and since he's bounded we know the
upper bound there's only like two to the
polyend states he could build anyways
right
yeah
you could tell him whatever you want to
build but he just doesn't have
the bricks to build the house right well
two to the polyend states that
encompasses basically all states if you
would because
you know after reasonable approximation
no no the number of states is doubly
exponential and then yeah and q that
states oh oh yeah right obviously oops
yeah two to the poly n is like roughly
the size of the basis right two to the
end of this says yeah
yeah my bad
yeah it's a good question i i don't know
my my hunch is similar to yours chin
made i think somehow it shouldn't be
possible to do
you know state synthesis for
for very complicated date but um
yeah i don't know if any proof or
disprove and the point is that you need
to query
like on qma qcma right because that's
the whole point is that can can the
verifier can the verifier build the
state
even that is the solution
it is like i think we believe that some
solutions just can't be built
right
yeah at least in the at least in our
approach um it's very important that the
communication is
quantum because the the verifier is
doing many queries and superpositions
that's a good question
and okay in your long video
yeah you talk about a constant run
protocol like do you have a candidate
for that or
uh yeah we do
uh
yeah it's like uh
like in the protocol we described it's
like a bunch of rounds and like the
state you know grows one cubit at a time
in each round the constant round
protocol like
uh the proverb just like you know send
sort of like a tableau of you know what
to say after each round should be and
then the verifier just sort of
picks a like random round and like
like you know verifies that like the two
states
like you know i've been getting on that
round or like that transition is
consistent
uh
i don't know if that was clear probably
not no no it is uh it's just okay then
you have to take care of their entangled
it's just that i'm trying to think yeah
yeah yeah and something like that yeah
okay okay
okay so yeah
well i don't know if anyone has any
other question or yeah i can i'd like
just to ask other final question uh do
you think that your characterization
could help us to find new
qma or any a new complete problem
um you mean a new computer
analog no no sure can you can
does your card characterization allow us
to prove new
new p to the q a log complete problems
so i mean there's one aspect of
when we have this translation for the uh
to construct
uh apx sim variants with with certain
properties so you can transl
so you can translate all these um
a query tree
uh create a choreograph with the bounded
separator number into a
uh api sim instance with also certain
geometric properties
uh yeah i was trying to think if the
there's some i don't know
not an apx scene but a new
a new problem that okay it does not look
like apx
no i think it must look like ap xm okay
okay
any other question
yeah if not so thanks again for
like for the wonderful talks and the
great discussion so
yeah stay tuned for the next sessions
you